[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
Sonntag der 11 oktober 1987 ist der eine
Arbeitstag im Leben von Sebastian Knauer
den er nie vergessen wird er arbeitet
damals für den Stern am Samstag hat ihn
sein Chef angerufen und gefragt ob er
nach Genf reisen kann um Uwe Barschel zu
intervenieren also macht Knauer sich
noch am Abend per Flugzeug auf den Weg
bei einer Zwischenlandung in Frankfurt
versuchter Barschel im Genfer Hotel
borrivage zu erreichen wo der
CDU-Politiker abgestiegen ist aber es
geht keiner ans Zimmertelefon an den
folgenden Tag erinnert sich Knauer
später gegenüber der Stuttgarter Zeitung
so ich bin nicht nach Genf gefahren um
einen Toten zu finden sondern um ein
politisches Interview mit dem ehemaligen
Ministerpräsidenten von
Schleswig-Holstein zu führen Barschel
hatte angedeutet dass er Entlastendes
Beweismaterial vorlegen können alle
Versuche in Genf Kontakt zu ihm zu
bekommen waren vergeblich gewesen
deshalb habe ich an die Zimmertür
geklopft als keine Reaktion kam habe ich
die gedrückt und die Tür öffnete sich zu
meiner Überraschung gleich geht Reporter
Sebastian Knauer in das Hotelzimmer mit
der Nummer 317 wir sind im zweiten Teil
des Podcasts über die barsche-affäre ich
bin Stefan Netzeband und war zur Zeit
des Geschehens in den 1980ern an der
gleichen Schule in Geesthacht an der
Elbe Schülersprecher wie gut 20 Jahre
vorher eben dieser Uwe Barschel seine
Rolle bei einer tödlichen Affäre an
diesem Gymnasium könnt ihr übrigens in
Teil 1 hören hallo und ich bin Mirko
Kasimir schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid
wir befinden uns also im Oktober
1987 in Genf Uwe Barschel ist als
schleswig-holsteinischer
Ministerpräsident zurückgetreten
angeblich hatte er den früheren Springer
Journalisten Rainer Pfeiffer
hauptsächlich dafür eingestellt sein
Gegner björn Engholm mit einem üblen
Schmutz Wahlkampf zu bezwingen aber
Pfeiffer wechselte die Seiten er
berichtete kurz vor der Landtagswahl im
September dem Spiegel von seinen
Machenschaften Barschel tritt alles ab
trat aber nach knapp einem Monat zurück
am Wochenende des zehnten und 11 oktober
1987 ist Barschel auf der Rückreise von
einem kurzen Aufenthalt auf Gran Canaria
und hat angeblich wichtige Unterlagen
dabei die er einem Reporter des stern
zeigen will Unterlagen die ihn entlasten
als Reporter Sebastian Knauer das offene
Hotelzimmer betritt entdeckte Akten und
Notizen zu den Vorgängen um die
barsche-affäre sternfotograf Hansjörg
anders knipst sie dann so erzählt Knauer
weiter nachdem ich die Notizen in den
Schlafraum zurückgelegt und zusätzlich
mit einer pocket Kamera ein paar Bilder
der Szenerie gemacht hatte klopfte ich
auf dem Weg hinaus auch an die
Badezimmertür
als ich sie dann öffnete sah ich den
leblosen Körper in der Badewanne liegen
es war eine Mischung aus Überraschung
Schock und Nichtwissen ich hatte keine
Erfahrung mit toten warum lag Barschel
angezogen in der Wanne weil Tod der Kopf
lag über Wasser deshalb dachte ich es
sei keine lebensbedrohliche Situation
nachdem ich mit der Kamera die Situation
dokumentiert hatte bin ich runter an die
Rezeption um die Hotelleitung zu
informieren aber Uwe Barschel der
politische Überflieger aus dem
beschaulichen Herzogtum Lauenburg ist
tot das Foto von Sebastian Knauer
schreibt Presse Geschichte zu sehen ist
Barsche der in Anzughose weißem Hemd und
dunklen Schlips wie schlafend in der
Wanne liegt die Beine zeigen nach rechts
der Oberkörper nach links Barschels Kopf
ruht auf einem Handtuch dass er sich um
die rechte Hand gewickelt hat er sieht
so friedlich aus dass Reporter Knauer
wie eben gehört erstmal gar nicht sicher
ist ob Barsche nicht einfach nur ganz
fest schläft aber er atmet nicht mehr
Stefan du hast ja schon erzählt dass
Barsche an deine Schule gegangen ist wie
war denn da jetzt so nach seinem Tod die
Stimmung eigentlich also wir von der
Schülerzeitung morgen Kaffee haben
damals eine Sonderschicht eingelegt denn
eigentlich war die September-Ausgabe
schon fertig und sollte zum Druck nach
Hamburg die haben wir immer mit so einem
blauen R4 von meiner Freundin zur
Druckerei in die Nähe des Gänsemarktes
gebracht wir haben also uns entschiedene
Sonderausgabe zu machen wir haben Leute
auf der Straße interviewt aber auch
Lehrer und Schüler ja und ich muss dir
sagen wir waren wie die meisten Schüler
bei uns auf links Kurs damals und
strickt gegen Barschel aber wir waren an
diesem Montag total erschrocken mit
welcher Helme da manche auf diesen Tod
reagiert haben es gab übrigens auch
einen Lehrer der mäßigen auf das
Gesamtbild einwirkte das war der Herr
Bruns ich glaube der war
Geschichtslehrer und der kannte Barsche
auch persönlich Bruns war völlig
erschüttert von dem Tod und erwarte uns
davor frühzeitig Schlüsse daraus zu
ziehen und man muss sagen mit den
Schlüssen taten sich ja wirklich auch
viele schwer Barschels Leiche wird
obduziert das Blut einer gründlichen
Analyse unterzogen schnell steht fest im
Körper des Mannes war ein tödlicher
Medikamentencocktail so findet sich eine
hohe Dosis eines
arzneimittelwirkstoffs Namens methybryon
es handelt sich um ein starkes
Schlafmittel und keinen Verbindung mit
Alkohol zu bewusstseinstörungen führen
es wird außerdem der sehr starke
Wirkstoff Cyclo barbital nachgewiesen
ebenfalls ein Betäubungsmittel außerdem
Tavor ein Mittel das angsthemd insgesamt
starb Marshall an einem halben Dutzend
Substanzen die gesamte Anordnung
inklusive starken Schlafmittel und der
gefüllten Weine entspricht den damaligen
Empfehlungen für einen sanften
Selbstmord das Protokoll bemerkt damals
die Menge an Substanzen kann man weder
unbemerkt noch aus Versehen zu sich
nehmen das Ergebnis der Gerichtsmedizin
lautet also
Suizid obwohl von Anfang an öffentlich
über gewisse Details diskutiert wird so
findet sich bei der Obduktion ein
Hämatom im oberen linken Stirnbereich
des Leichnams also ein Bluterguss war
Barsche geschubst worden hatte ihn
jemand überfallen und zur Einnahme der
Medikamente gezwungen der damals
Beteiligte Pathologe Jansen gibt sich
überzeugt viel naheliegender war es das
Barsche sich diese unterblutung selbst
zugezogen hatte etwa am Türrahmen oder
durch Aufstoß am Badewannenrand so viel
erstmal zum Mordtheorie sie bräuchte im
übrigen ja noch einen Täter und ein
Motiv dazu dann gleich auch mehr es gibt
aber auch Überlegung dass jemand Barsche
beim Suizid geholfen hat dass dieser
Jemand z.B den Angst immer Tavor
anreichte und später als Barsche schon
schläfrig wurde dafür sorgte dass er
eben auch den Rest runterschluckt zwei
Merkwürdigkeiten sprechen dafür das noch
jemand dabei war es finden sich
keinerlei Verpackungen der Medikamente
und ebenso wenig findet die
Spurensicherung eine Flasche Rotwein die
Barsche laut Hotel bestellt hatte nach
Barsches Tod bleiben also zwei ganz
große Fragen strittig war es wirklich
Selbstmord und war Barsche der alleinige
Bösewicht den politischen Teil der
Affäre an beiden Fragen arbeiten sich
noch jahrelang Leute ab am dritten
februar 1988 beendet der erste
Untersuchungsausschuss des
Schleswig-Holsteinischen Landtages seine
Arbeit das Fazit zwei Tage später der
Anstoß zur Schmutzkampagne kam von
barcel selbst tatsächlich haben seine
Mitarbeiter ihre eidesstattlichen
Versicherungen zu barschelsgunsten
mittlerweile offiziell zurückgezogen ach
der mai 1988 die Neuwahl des Landtages
wird ein Siegeszug für björn Engholm
er holt mit der SPD die absolute
Mehrheit in Kiel er ist jetzt ein
Superstar der Partei
1991 wird er mit 94% der Stimmen
Bundesvorsitzender der SPD als
Nachfolger von Hans-Jochen Vogel aber
das Glück hält nicht lange das ist ein
bisschen vielleicht auch der Leitspruch
dieser ganzen Geschichte das Glück hält
nicht lange also wieder ist es die freie
Presse die aufzeigt wo was faul ist und
wieder geht es um Rainer Pfeiffer die
Zeitschrift Stern berichtet Anfang 1993
über Geld Geschenke der SPD an Pfeifer
der Mann der Engholm mit seinen
Enthüllung zum Sieg Verhalten hat ist
ständig Pleite also überbringt ihm so
der Stern der frühere SPD Landessprecher
Nils mehrere 10.000 Mark 40.000 sonst
genau gewesen sein die kommen laut Nils
von einem Bauunternehmer der anonym
bleiben wollte
diese Erklärung ist so unglaubwürdig
dass die SPD später eine andere
nachliefert diesmal heißt es
Sozialminister Günther Jansen aber das
Geld in kleinen Scheinen zusammen mit
seiner Frau über Jahre in der
Küchenschublade gesammelt Jansen erklärt
wörtlich es ist brisant aber dass man
jemandem der so durchhängt so in ein
soziales Loch fällt helfen muss dafür
stehen wir beide gerade das Pendel
dieser ganzen politischen Schweinereien
schwingt jetzt zurück und trifft die SPD
hat sie Pfeiffer im Nachhinein für seine
Enthüllung entlohnt oder konnte Pfeiffer
die SPD damit erpressen das sozial
Demokraten frühzeitig Kontakt zu ihm
hatten oder war die gesamte Affäre sogar
komplett völlig inszeniert das würde der
CDU natürlich sehr gut passen lässt sich
so aber nicht beweisen aber wieder gibt
es einen Untersuchungsausschuss in Kiel
und der weiß björn Engholm nach dass er
schon viele Wochen vor den Bedingungen
des september 1987 von der pfeiffersache
wusste er hat also öffentlich gelogen
Engholm ist politisch erledigt am 3 mai
1993 sagt er im Bewusstsein der
geleisteten und getanen Arbeit und in
der Absicht mein Land und meine Partei
davor zu bewahren mit meinem politischen
Fehler identifiziert zu werden werde ich
mein Amt als Ministerpräsident und meine
Funktionen in der SPD aufgeben BAM auf
Engholm folgt in Kiel Heide Simones hat
viele Jahre regiert aber jüngere Hörer
kennen Sie vielleicht eher noch als
hoppelheide aus Let's Dance auf
Bundesebene wird jetzt Rudolf Scharping
Chef der SPD der wird später noch mit
einer peinlichen pool-totelei von sich
reden machen aber das tut hier nichts
zur Sache fest steht in der sogenannten
Barschel-Affäre war nichts so
schwarz-weiß wie es anfangs schien
Stefan was glaubst du das eine gute
Frage danke Mirko ich glaube das Barsche
durchaus wusste was er mit Pfeife
erreichen wollte aber dass er wiederum
ein falsches Spiel auf beiden Seiten
geführt hat dieser Pfeifer und ich bin
mir ziemlich sicher dass Barsche 1987
ein ernsthaftes Problem mit Medikamenten
hatte also ich war zum Beispiel als
Pauker im Schulorchester mal mit bei der
Eröffnung eines Krankenhauses Neubaus in
Geesthacht da war Barschel der Stargast
und der ist wirklich Augenblicke nach
seiner Ankunft da in dieser großen Halle
völlig benebelt auf seinem Stuhl
eingepennt und hat auch durch gereizt
die ganze Veranstaltung über ja ich weiß
die Medikamente spielen ja auch in den
Debatten über seinen Tod eine wichtige
Rolle ich glaube darauf sollten wir noch
mal eingehen oh ja Mirko was
Verschwörungstheorien angeht da wurde
Barsche ja sowas ähnliches wie der
Kennedy von der Kieler Förde hier sind
mal ein paar Gedanken Gebilde die ich
uns beiden zusammengetragen habe die
immer wieder kursierten Südafrikas
Geheimdienst spritzte schläft in die
Fußsohlen um den Mord zu verschleiern
Barsche soll seine Kontakte zu
ddr-waffenhändler genutzt haben um die
vom Konkurs bedrohte HDW-Werft in Kiel
zu retten angeblicher Plan U-Boote für
Südafrika trotz un-verbot mit Wisser
Barschel musste demnach sterben oder CIA
oder Mossad töteten Barsche mit einem
Gift das über die Haut einwirkt bin
Minuten tötet und später nicht
nachweisbar ist mögliches Motiv wieder
Waffen Deals diesmal mit Libyen eine
weitere Theorie aus dieser Ecke der Welt
Barschel habe Wind von Waffendienst
zwischen Israel und dem Iran bekommen
diese sollten über Schleswig-Holstein
laufen und Barsche habe sich dem
entgegengestellt das behauptet der
ehemalige Mossad Agent Viktor austrowski
in einem Buch er nennt sogar den Namen
der angeblichen Operation Hannibal nach
der Wiedervereinigung kursieren auch
Vermutungen der antikommunistisch
eingestellte Barschel sei von der sie
ermordet worden oder auch dem KGB und
jetzt fehlen eigentlich nur noch UFOs
als Teil einer Verschwörung ja okay
scherz beiseite seriöser sind
Überlegungen das Barsche die in seinem
Blut gefundenen Stoffe nicht alle allein
hätte nehmen können weil er frühzeitig
bewusstlos werden musste über derlei
Theorien streiten Toxikologen und die
Gerichtsmediziner von damals noch
Jahrzehnte danach wir wollen das muss
auch mal erwähnt werden hier niemanden
veralbern der sich ernsthaft um die
Wahrheit bemüht im Fall Barsche denn das
muss man auch sagen die schlampige
Arbeit der Schweizer Polizei hat Zweifel
noch bestärkt oder sogar erst möglich
gemacht zum Beispiel war auf den Tatort
Fotos kaum was zu erkennen weil der Film
kaputt war und im ersten
Obduktionsbericht wurden Standardfragen
wie zum Beispiel der Todeszeitpunkt
erstmal gar nicht erwähnt den späteren
nach Untersuchungen wurde zudem die DNA
einer weiteren Person im Hotelzimmer 317
des ori warsch nachgewiesen und zwar an
einem Kleidungsstück
aber diese Spur konnte weder dem
todesgeschehen noch einer Person
zugeordnet werden auch was Barsche und
Pfeifer wirklich miteinander abgemacht
hatten lässt sich nicht mehr neu
nachfragen denn Pfeifer nahm sein Wissen
am 12 August
2015 mit ins Grab da war längst von den
Folgen eines Schlaganfalls gezeichnet er
stürzte unglücklich zwischen die Gitter
seines Bettes und erstickte dort und
Mirko lass uns den Podcast an meiner
Schule beenden wo wir ihn ja auch
begonnen hatten na da bin ich ja jetzt
ja mal gespannt das darfst du auch sein
das 50-jährige Jubiläum des OHG des
Otto-Hahn-Gymnasium wurde 1990 groß
gefeiert mit vielen Reden Live Musik und
eine Ausstellung ich war auch da ich
studierte damals gerade und vor die
Schule hatten anonyme Witzbolde eine
leere weiße Badewanne gestellt mit einem
Schild dran darauf stand nicht jeder
wird 50
das ist wirklich ein sehr makaberer
Scherz oh mein Gott das ist ein Übel
Macara Schatz absolut übel und wenn ich
in dieser podcastreihe ausnahmsweise mal
ein bisschen pathetisch werden darf das
genau das ist was unsere Gesellschaft
kaputt machen kann dass wir anderen
gegenüber Mitleid los sind weil sie
politisch eben auf der anderen Seite
stehen ich rate das auch heute übrigens
noch allen die sich politisch zoffen sie
sollten nicht vergessen dass das
Gegenüber jeweils auch ein Mensch ist so
genug moralisches jetzt das war auf
jeden Fall eine Geschichte die einen
nicht loslässt mich nicht loslässt hat
man vielleicht auch gehört hilfreich
beim Erzählen waren neben dem Archiv des
Axel Springer Verlages zwei Chroniken
auf den Seiten des NDR die einen guten
Überblick gegeben haben das Interview
der Stuttgarter Zeitung mit Sebastian
Knauer der den Toten Barsche gefunden
hat sowie zur dönitz-affäre ein Projekt
meiner alten Schule die Klasse 13a das
Jahrgang 2011 hat das Geschehen
zusammengefasst einen Link zum PDF
findet ihr in den Show Notes Aufnahme
und schnitt Toni Hayer Postproduktion
durch weight watch Studios München falls
Ihr Anregungen Kritik Lob oder
fallvorschläge für uns hat dann schreibt
uns gerne eine E-Mail oder eine
Nachricht bei Instagram den
entsprechenden Links findet ihr in den
shonouts danke dass ihr dabei wart oder
Mirko und euer Stefan
und jetzt lassen wir gerne diese
dramatische schlussmusik laufen und wenn
ihr wollt erzähle ich euch dann noch
warum ich bei der gesagt hat Zeitung
gefeuert wurde da bin ich aber gespannt
also
jetzt kommt der der Hidden Track
ich habe als junger Reporter ich glaube
ich war auch noch Schüler ein Bericht
über einen Angelverein gemacht es gab
zwei Angelvereine in Geesthacht früh auf
und liefert sagt und ich habe diesen
Bericht abgeliefert der wurde auch
gedruckt und ein paar Tage später eine
Woche später kam ich wieder in die
Redaktion um irgendwas anderes abzugeben
und der der Lokalreporter der Chefin
gesagt hatte du stefan hat dir
eigentlich keiner gesagt dass du
gefeuert worden ist tut mir leid nee ja
sagt er du hast in dem Artikel über nie
verzagt hast du früh aufgeschrieben und
der Vereinsvorsitzende hat sich beim
zeitungsboss im Bergedorf beschwert also
wir brauchen nicht erstmal nicht mehr
und so hätte eine Journalisten Karriere
enden können aber wie er in diesem
Podcast merkt sie ging irgendwie ging
sie weiter du bist halt zäh und
hartnäckig so ist es okay wunderbar
bis zur nächsten Folge jetzt ist
wirklich Schluss ausmachen ausschalten
tschüss